bonsoir et bienvenue à tous nous sommes
le 12 mai voici les principaux titres à
Maurepas la fermeture du centre nautique
non fini plus de faire parler
l'opposition socialiste au conseil
municipal attaque directement le maire
UMP et Grégory garesti les catholiques
des Yvelines viennent de participer aux
assises pour la formation affective et
sexuelle des 10-18 ans état des lieux
mais aussi réflexions et échanges
étaient au programme et puis jusqu'au 24
mai se déroulent la Quinzaine du
commerce équitable l'occasion de faire
le bilan sur ce système d'échange qui
permet de réduire les inégalités
invitées vers l'arrière Rodriguez
responsable communication de la
Fondation max havlar
les pompiers des Yvelines présents sur
les champs le 14 juillet pour le
traditionnel rendez-vous de la fête
nationale 80 soldats du feu
professionnel défilerons sur les pavés
de la capitale parmi eux vins seront
issus des différents centres de secours
du département les sélections des
candidats viennent de débuter
je vous le disais en titre l'opposition
se mobilise à mort pas après l'annonce
de la fermeture définitive du centre
nautique communal ce sont les
socialistes donc qui dénoncent les choix
du maire UMP regardez ce reportage signé
Mélanie poquet
mord pas sans piscine c'est non
l'opposition mortazienne s'organise pour
signifier sont mécontentements le grief
l'annonce le cap mai dernier de la
fermeture du centre nautique de la ville
par le maire Grégory garestier le maire
s'appuie sur plusieurs audits et met en
avant la sécurité des usagers on a fait
un audit l'audit du mois de mars de
cette année qui disait que il y avait
des travaux à faire à court terme jamais
à aucun moment on a noté que la
population de la piscine les usagers
étaient en danger jamais ça a été mis
dans le alors le dernier rapport là qui
est sorti c'est donc le troisième
là il ne dit pas qu'il faut fermer la
piscine non plus du jour au lendemain
les élus d'opposition ils voient plutôt
une fermeture liée à des raisons
économiques les travaux envisagés par
l'audit s'ils étaient engagés se montrer
à plusieurs millions d'euros
ce que nous mettons en évidence c'est
l'enfumage du maire qui drapait de la
responsabilité finalement cache son
véritable projet qui est une fermeture
définitive de la piscine dans le but de
récupérer un budget qui pourra servir
certainement à financer sa police
municipale ou encore d'autres frais qui
n'existaient pas à mort pas et qu'il a
amené les crédits ont déjà été budgétés
le maire les connaît c'est à lui de les
mettre en place mais en conseil
municipal il a refusé refusé de ce qu'il
avait budgété lui-même de mettre les
premiers crédits c'est un signe qui nous
montre qu'il ne veut pas d'une piscine
publique à Maurepas
des politiques publiques qui sont
complètement différentes je ne vois pas
le rapport entre la police municipale et
le problème de la piscine de Maurepas et
j'ai dit au morpien que je souhaitais
évidemment une piscine à Maurepas
puisque les audits sont claires il
l'équipement menace la sécurité du
public j'ai commandé une étude de
faisabilité
en concertation évidemment avec les
maires des villes voisines qui sont
partis prenantes pour savoir s'il faut
réhabiliter combien ça va nous coûter
combien de temps va falloir ou si il
vaut mieux détruire et reconstruire le
centre nautique est fermé depuis le 3
avril dernier en cause une corrosion
avancée de plusieurs éléments
métalliques de l'établissement une
pétition circule actuellement sur
Internet elle est depuis ce week-end
disponible en version papier elle a déjà
collecté près de 700 signatures
c'était une première vendredi et samedi
dernier à Versailles 350 personnes
présentes à l'appel de Monseigneur Erico
Monnier pour une journée d'assise autour
de la sexualité des 10-18 ans des tables
rondes et des ateliers pour les parents
les enseignants pour les prêtres
également et ils ont échangé ensemble
sur un sujet longtemps considéré comme
tabou le reportage de Williams
apporter des réponses concrètes en phase
avec la nouvelle génération voilà
l'objectif de mon Seigneur Éric aumônier
évêque de Versailles durant deux jours
350 personnes se sont rendues au lycée
privé Saint Jean Husse pour écouter les
réponses de l'église sur un sujet
sensible l'affectivité et la sexualité
des jeunes l'objectif de ces aciers
c'est que se diffuse à l'intérieur du
diocèse sur l'ensemble des paroisses et
chez tous les chrétiens mais plus
largement une bonne écoute des jeunes et
une meilleure aide de ce qu'ils vivent
pour qu'il devienne des adultes dans la
société qui ne seront pas fermés sur
eux-mêmes mais qui seront capables
d'aimer et qui sont capables d'être les
uns et les autres
témoins autour d'eux que la vie vaut la
peine d'être vécue l'Église diocésaine
affirme ainsi son intérêt et son
engagement sur ce sujet longtemps tabou
au programme de ces deux jours table
ronde et atelier pour poser un regard
lucide sur ce que vivent les jeunes
aujourd'hui et permettre aux parents de
comprendre la sexualité de leurs enfants
sont très contents des intervenants des
échanges de se rencontrer de pouvoir
libérer la parole c'est un sujet
compliqué évidemment et c'était aussi un
des enjeux c'est de dire on a peur on
sait pas comment s'en saisir c'est
normal mais partant de là essayons d'y
travailler ensemble
face à une forte demande la nécessité de
ses assises a été constaté dès 2011 par
Monseigneur aumônier à l'issue du Synode
dure ses un
juste relation les utiliser les bons
termes pour essayer d'être en même temps
le plus efficace et en même temps on
cherche pas d'abord l'efficacité mais
simplement de faire au mieux quoi une
grande première pour l'Église catholique
qui ne compte pas en rester là
Monseigneur aumônier souhaite la mise en
place de projets concrets dans le
diocèse
ce week-end la France commémorait
l'abolition de l'esclavage le 10 mai
c'est la date de la Journée nationale
des mémoires de la traite de l'esclavage
et de leur abolition et à cette occasion
la ville de La Verrière a lancé toute
une série de manifestations sous le
label printemps de la tolérance Mélanie
paquet
favoriser le dialogue et l'échange c'est
le but du Printemps de la tolérance qui
a débuté ce week-end à La Verrière pour
la première journée ces vers l'histoire
de l'esclavage que la commune s'est
tournée c'est une décision que l'on a
prise il y a déjà plusieurs mois et qui
a été renforcé par les événements qui
sont passés au mois de mois de janvier
qui nous ont beaucoup frappé et on a
donc décidé de de faire en sorte que le
printemps soit un petit peu symbole de
d'amitié et de tolérance et donc cette
journée
rentrée complètement dans ce cadre là au
programme exposition pour comprendre le
marronnage quand les esclaves prenaient
la fuite lecture de poèmes et compte sur
l'esclavage et vente de produits
artisanaux d'Afrique et des Caraïbes de
quoi faire découvrir aussi la culture
africaine natal
n'est pas parti seul
des fous avec on a tué l'homme en tant
qu'être humain mais on n'a pas tué son
esprit donc il a emmené avec lui sa
culture la culture de du coin où il est
né la nation on appelait ça des nations
lutter contre le racisme rassemblé et
comprendre l'histoire et des idées
appréciées par les spectateurs le mois
de mai c'est le mois spécial pour qu'on
apporte un peu notre concours à
expliquer les choses qui sont passées
dans l'humanité entre les hommes de
cette société pourquoi il y a eu tant de
méchanceté pour aller à eu ce commerce
inacceptable et inhumain qui est celui
des hommes les hommes réduits à la
marchandise et puis je me sens très
concernée par cette journée de par mes
origines et puis aussi par
intellectuellement quoi tu trouves que
c'est quelque chose de très important ça
devrait être beaucoup plus diffusée je
trouve il y a peut-être pas assez de
publicité ou de
onces faites à ce sujet là c'est dommage
parce que je pense que il y a beaucoup
de gens qui seraient venus le printemps
de la tolérance de la verrière se
déroule jusqu'au 17 juin
économie les entreprises de plus de 300
salariés doivent avoir négocié un
contrat de génération dans lequel figure
un volet transmission des savoirs et des
compétences c'est maintenant une
obligation légale une réunion sur cette
thématique a donc été organisée par la
maison de l'emploi et de la formation
ainsi que par le club face Catherine
zulator
un système 12000 collaborateurs dont
7000 en France une moyenne d'âge de 36
ans ces jeunes pourtant la question de
la transmission des savoirs et des
compétences se posent pour cette
multinationale spécialisée dans le
nucléaire et qui ouvre 1500 recrutements
cette année aujourd'hui un système c'est
est né dans les années 60 66 exactement
dans les métiers à liés au nucléaire
donc on a des experts qui sont rentrés
dans la société dans ces années-là qui
ont construit les centrales et
aujourd'hui on est sur le démantèlement
des centrales donc du coup c'est eux qui
ont toute la technicité de ce qui s'est
passé il y a plus de 40 ans et pour
transmettre c'est savoir depuis 2008
l'entreprise a mis en place des
instituts de formation c'est accompagné
d'un programme dédié aux apprentis d'un
principe de compagnonnage et de
parrainage il n'y a pas d'obligation
légale en la matière mais les
entreprises de plus de 300 salariés sont
censés avoir négocié un contrat de
génération qui intègre ce volet
transmission des compétences et sur ce
plan tout n'est pas si simple
c'est pas inné de transmettre tout le
monde n'a pas aimé la volonté ni la
capacité à transmettre ça se prépare ça
s'organise déjà faire un état
d'éluciation voir ce qu'on transmet dans
quel objectif et puis préparer les
acteurs pour transmettre et formaliser
les choses et les tuteurs et les
apprenants qui vont aussi recevoir voilà
c'est compétences pour organiser
organiser tout ça c'est une vraie
question aujourd'hui de dire comment je
permets à ma société et aux
collaborateurs qui sont dans ma société
de transmettre du coup leur savoir que
ça soit des savoirs être des
savoir-faire comment je leur permets de
du coup de donner du coup soit une jeune
génération soit à des personnes qui
changent de métier c'est ces
informations là et comment je les rend
aussi à l'aise à transmettre ces
informations une réunion d'information
est organisée par la maison de l'emploi
et le club face à la demande des
entreprises
l'idée c'était d'avoir un expert
spécialiste de cette question donc nous
avons fait appel pour cela à la Réactine
de France et également d'avoir des
témoignages d'entreprises donc des
choses beaucoup plus concrètes qui
permettent puisque c'est aussi une
demande des entreprises de pouvoir
échanger des bonnes pratiques et en la
matière le premier conseil à donner aux
entreprises
identifier les compétences à transmettre
et avoir un regard sur la pyramide des
âges de sa société pour ne pas attendre
le dernier moment des conseils peuvent
être pris sur le site de la rate la
Maison de l'Emploi sert également de
relais
on reste dans l'économie mais avec une
autre façon de la concevoir bonsoir
Valérie bonsoir Valeria Rodriguez
bienvenue vous êtes la responsable
relation presse c'est communication de
la Fondation Max havlar qui fait partie
des principaux acteurs du commerce
équitable jusqu'au 24 mai c'est la
Quinzaine du commerce équitable on va en
parler en détail avec vous auparavant
savez-vous ce qu'est le commerce
équitable c'est notre question du jour
réponse avec ce micro-trottoir c'est une
répartition des bénéfices entre le
surtout le producteur et puis les
consommateurs peu importe trop non c'est
quoi ça pas trop non je sais que c'est
des produits qui sont très régionaux et
qui sont payés directement au petit
fabricant un trou je sais que il faut
payer au juste prix ce que produisent
les pays je dirais en voie de
développement d'acheter des produits qui
seront
pas moins cher mais
dont le personnel qu'on va utiliser dans
les autres pays ne seront pas exploitées
non pas du tout c'est un commerce qui
permet de redistribuer davantage les
valeurs entre le producteur le
distributeur
Rodriguez pour Max Avelin votre réaction
aujourd'hui ça a fait son chemin cette
idée du commerce équitable mais il y a
encore un peu de travail effectivement
ça fait
plus de 40 ans que le commerce équitable
l'existence en France Max est né il y a
un peu plus de 20 ans et l'idée a fait
un bon chemin mais comme on le voit dans
ce micro-trottoir pas tout le monde
c'est exactement ce que c'est que le
commerce équitable en ce moment et
justement la Quinzaine du commerce
équitable c'est le moment pour nous pour
les acteurs du commerce équitable pour
pouvoir expliquer aux consommateurs
qu'est-ce que ce commerce c'est d'autres
formes définition du commerce équitable
en quelques mots en quelques mots je
dirais que le commerce équitable c'est
une autre forme de commerce qui suit des
règles commerciales plus justes pour le
maillon le plus faible de la chaîne qui
est le producteur agricole celui qui
travaille la terre et qui du coup
travaille pour les produire les aliments
que nous mangeons tous les jours au
début au tout début au commencement de
cette idée du commerce équitable on
quand on pensait commercial on pensait
au café par exemple aujourd'hui c'est
pas le cas on trouve plein de produits
oui depuis 20 ans on trouve plein de
produits effectivement on trouve bien
évidemment beaucoup de café encore mais
on trouve aussi du thé du chocolat du
des bananes du riz et on trouve aussi du
coton équitable par exemple donc c'est
des vêtements aussi il y a des vêtements
quand on équitable effectivement on
trouve pas uniquement des produits
alimentaires alors donc c'est un peu
mieux connu on l'a vu avec le
micro-trottoir et puis on l'imagine
aussi aujourd'hui on en parle beaucoup
plus facilement mais pour autant est-ce
que c'est utilisé est-ce que les
consommateurs franchissent le pas est-ce
qu'ils font attention à leur
consommation pour utiliser ces produits
du commerce équitable alors oui c'est un
marché qui est en perpétuel croissance
par exemple entre 2013 et 2004 et 2014
on a une croissance de 10% des des du
chiffre d'affaires des produits
labellisés faire traite max Havelar mais
il y a encore du chemin
les
les consommateurs ne font que par
exemple 6 euros d'achat et par an chaque
Français consomme 6 euros par an de
communication c'est quoi c'est parce que
les gens pensent que c'est plus cher
d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est plus cher ou
c'est un peu plus cher oui c'est c'est
un peu plus cher mais beaucoup moins de
ce qu'on imagine et ce mais je pense que
surtout il y a une méconnaissance encore
de ce que c'est le commerce équitable et
des bénéfices qui peuvent engendrer pour
les producteurs mais c'est intéressant
parce que les Français en même temps ils
sont très susceptibles et très sensibles
à la consommation responsable et ils
disent qu'ils veulent consommer
responsable pourquoi pour défendre les
droits des travailleurs et pour protéger
l'environnement et il se trouve que
quand on leur demande c'est quoi la
consommation responsable les Français
pensent au local au made in France
beaucoup plus que commerce équitable or
le commerce équitable justement il est
là pour
protéger les droits des petits
producteurs et pour défendre
l'environnement pour protéger
l'environnement mais au-delà de nos
frontières donc des valeurs qui sont
universelles justement nous on veut dire
aux Français qu'elles sont universelles
quels sont les bienfaits justement pour
ces producteurs alors les producteurs
dans le commerce équitable ils
travaillent d'une ils travaillent
organisé ils sont toujours autour
d'organisation ils perçoivent un prix
minimum garanti qui leur permet toujours
de vendre au-dessus de leur coup de
production ce qui est déjà super
important et après il perçoivent une
prime de développement qui elle est
collective elle est versée par
l'acheteur à toute la coopérative avec
laquelle ils peuvent faire des projets
soit dans le social comme des écoles des
centres de santé etc soit dans
l'économique pour développer encore plus
leur activité aujourd'hui combien on
bénéficiant on parle de plus d'un
million de producteurs sont les chiffres
que vous avancez oui dans le système
fait retrait de Max avela on a
actuellement un million et demi de
producteurs dans 74 pays en Afrique en
Amérique latine et en Asie pour
développer ce commerce équitable est-ce
qu'il faut aussi des relais locaux
j'entends des enseignes par exemple
Artisans du Monde c'est peut-être la
plus connue
il faut des relais vous les avez ces
relais locaux aussi parce que la grande
surface les grandes surfaces la grande
distribution joue pas forcément le jeu
alors les produits
labellisés par trade Max havlar se
retrouve dans tous les circuits de
distribution se retrouvent dans les
grandes surfaces se retrouvent dans les
circuit bio et ça retrouve aussi dans ce
qu'on appelle la consommation hors
domicile c'est-à-dire la distribution
automatique les cantines scolaires ou
d'entreprises etc qui ou dans les cafés
dans les hôtels dans les restaurants le
commerce équitables et maintenant un peu
partout et vous avez raison nous avons
besoin de tous nous avons besoin des
entreprises qui s'engagent à changer
leur pratique du coup à faire leur
commerce à travers le commerce équitable
des enseignes de grandes distribution ou
pas de toutes les enseignes et des
consommateurs qui quand ils vont
consommer des produits qui viennent du
sud forcément comme le café le chocolat
ou le coton ou les bananes qui pensent
que aux conditions commerciales dans
lesquelles ces produits ont été changés
mais les grandes surfaces jouent le jeu
aujourd'hui plus facilement que par le
passé
les grandes surfaces ont un engagement
vis-à-vis du commerce équitable on
retrouve maintenant les produits dans
toutes les dans toutes les chaînes de
grandes de grandes distribution et en
avance aussi ces produits peut-être plus
difficile pour le consommateur de s'y
retrouver il faut avoir envie de
consommer justement d'utiliser ce mode
de consommation pour trouver ces
produits lorsqu'on va faire ses courses
il faut savoir ce qu'on devient pour ça
c'est pas on va pas au détour d'un rayon
se dire ah oui au fait il y a le
commerce équitable je pourrais changer
ma consommation
ils sont pas toujours très facile à
trouver quoi que ça dépend des enseignes
mais il se retrouve souvent par exemple
dans les réseaux bio parce qu'il faut
savoir que maintenant par exemple 77%
des produits labellisés faire traitement
sont également bio donc souvent on va
les retrouver sur dans les rayons bio et
c'est vrai que on voudrait bien tout ce
qui est un peu plus dans les rayons et
ça passe peut-être par une incitation
gouvernementale quel rapport vous avez
avec les pouvoirs publics avec les
politiques sur cette question là ce qui
vous soutiennent est-ce qu'il y a une
incitation qui est faite on travaille
avec avec le gouvernement surtout
surtout autour de la plateforme pour le
commerce équitable qui réunit tous les
acteurs de ce secteur et il y a eu deux
ans il y a deux ans le gouvernement a
lancé un plan national pour le commerce
équitable justement pour appuyer les
coopératives au sud et aussi les marques
engagées et au nord donc oui on y
travaille mais quand on voit que le
commerce qui tarde ne représente même
pas 1% des échanges mondiaux on sait
qu'on a beaucoup à faire et qu'on a
besoin de tout le monde beaucoup pas
faire et le travail et qui est mené
pendant cette quinzaine cette quinzaine
du commerce équitable va permettre
chaque chacun chaque consommateur d'en
savoir un petit peu plus il y aura des
opérations qui vont être dispensés un
petit peu partout l'ouverture d'un
espace éphémère notamment ça c'est pour
ceux qui vont se rendre sur Paris pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots oui bien sûr
alors c'est un espace éphémère qui
s'appelle shemax qu'on a voulu justement
ouvrir pour que les gens puissent venir
parler avec nous échanger sur le
commerce équitable il y aura des
producteurs il y aura des animations
avec les marques de café et avec
d'autres marques de chocolat etc qui
vont faire des animations tout au long
de cette quinzaine il est au 10 rue
pulmart dans le 10e arrondissement de
Paris et tout le monde est invité pour
venir justement à ça on aura aussi des
producteurs de coton qui vont faire un
peu le tour de France dans 17 villes
pour parler des enjeux pour les
producteurs de coton en Afrique de
l'Ouest par exemple aussi ça c'est
l'objectif de développer un peu plus le
coton je reviens à ce que vous disiez
d'ailleurs au début de cet entretien
textile coton on en trouve encore assez
peu et il faut développer cet aspect là
oui tout à fait on en trouve le coton
équitable en fait en France il se trouve
surtout dans des vêtements de travail
mais très peu dans le prêt-à-porter et
c'est justement pour ça qu'on est à
cette quinzaine on va essayer de
sensibiliser le grand public mais aussi
plus largement pour qu'il y ait plus de
coton équitable dans nos vêtements
programmation donc pour cette quinzaine
du commerce équitable à retrouver sur le
site Internet de la Fondation max merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau Valérie
Rodriguez responsable communication pour
cette fondation la quinzaine c'est
jusqu'au 24 mai direction Versailles à
présent et cette première depuis le 19e
siècle la création d'une oeuvre pérenne
dans les jardins du Château Le Bosquet
du théâtre d'eau a repris vie il est
visible pour le public à partir de mardi
à partir d'aujourd'hui Catherine zulato
sur des images signées Élodie moines
Louis XIV n'aurait pas été mécontent
voir danser autour du Bosquet du théâtre
d'eau un bosquet détruit en 1775 par son
petit-fils Louis XVI puis définitivement
abandonné après la tempête de 2001 et
qui a repris racine sous l'impulsion
d'un paysagiste et d'un sculpteur une
œuvre contemporaine qui de plus est
pérenne au milieu d'un lieu chargé
d'histoire je pense que ce qui a séduit
les membres du jury et ce qui moi m'a
particulièrement enthousiasmée c'est
justement la justesse du propos la
justesse du propos des deux artistes ils
se sont inscrits dans l'histoire le
passé ici nourrit le présent depuis le
19e siècle on n'avait pas fait une
création de cette ampleur dans les
jardins de Versailles quatre ans de
travaux ont été nécessaires pour
réaliser ce bosquet autour du chiffre 3
d'une fontaine moderne et d'un plan
d'eau j'ai eu cette envie de me poser
sur l'eau sur ses grandes ces grands
miroirs et j'ai commencé à réfléchir
quelles étaient les liens entre le roi
et la danse et le jardin et là j'ai
trouvé des des pâtes danse qui était
chorégraphiées par feuillets et j'ai
redessiné donc c'est ces sculptures de
façon à faire danser le roi sur l'eau
aujourd'hui
ici même si l'oeuvre est moderne le
nôtre est partout le jardinier du roi a
inspiré le paysagiste ce que je voulais
c'était inventer les formes qui n'ont
pas existé historiquement sur des
racines qui ont toujours des racines
culturelles quelque part mais qui
raconte une histoire qui correspondent à
ce bosquet qui soit sur la capacité
que le nôtre avait d'être le vraiment le
père de
l'illusion le bosquet du théâtre d'eau a
repris ses lettres de noblesse depuis ce
mardi il sera dorénavant l'oeuvre la
plus avant-gardiste du château une belle
revanche après avoir été si longtemps
oublié
un dernier mot de politique avant de
refermer ce journal Jean-Paul Huchon qui
jette l'éponge il ne sera pas candidat à
la primaire socialiste pour les
régionales en Île-de-France le président
sortant se range donc derrière Claude
barthelon président de l'Assemblée
nationale rendez-vous mercredi aux
horaires habituels peuvent être
Catherine zulato pour une nouvelle
édition du journal tout de suite le 7 8
société retour sur les événements
tragiques qui ont endeuillé la commune
de trappes et cette question quelles
enseignements très bonne soirée